So now let me bring up the whole
famous approach of using SIFT for
doing feature detection,
scaling the features, by David Lowe.
Reference is also there if
you want to look it up.
It's also on the website.
Basically what we're interested
in is finding the local maximum,
both in scale and in space.
Basically the measurements we want
to do is difference of Gaussians.
I already showed you before.
And difference of Gaussians basically
creates a pyramid of the difference of
Gaussians within each object.
So it captures the scale.
By looking at the derivative information
of the difference in variation of
Gaussians across scale and also space.
So here, basically coming up again
we have space, x y, scale going up.
We basically again do the same
processing, but again for each and
every aspect of it we're going to be
now doing difference of Gaussians.
So in this case the difference of
Gaussians in x and y for each and
every image, but also doing the same for
difference of Gaussians in scale.